right now I'm standing on the
Palestinian side of the wall it
separates the Palestinians from the
Israelis according to the Israeli
government the separation wall is a
security measure built to protect
against terrorist attacks and has
resulted in a dramatic drop in Israeli
deaths and casualties it's also a
flashpoint there's been a lot of
violence here a lot of clashes between
the Israeli forces and Palestinians rock
throwing tear gas killings and of course
right here the ultimate symbol of
divisive Nostromo kissing the guard
tower apparently he thinks it's his
fourth wife while we were filming at the
wall I was confronted by a group of
pro-palestinian activists what do you
think of this war is this a normal world
well no I don't think any war like this
is normal do you know it's sad it's like
that's been a prison at the end of the
day that's not you don't you don't
create peace by segregating people and
they can't keep saying where they throw
rocks you've got m16 you've got tanks
you can't compare that there's also
another side of it where there are
people who would say we don't want we
don't want the Jewish state to exist at
all we don't want to accept that but you
would be welcome to be welcomed into
their home
no we're we're on our way to we wanted
to go to a refugee no we're not going
with the IDF we were headed we were let
me ask you a question do you what is
what do you see as a solution as a
solution woke one America has to stop
giving his or ten million dollars a day
just for weapons once the weapons stop
Israel has no choice but to speak to
talk about peace American people know
where their money was going and the fact
that when they went when when our
wonderful Army's president got elected
and people are very sad that that arms
let's not go after him for having orange
hair now you're getting personal with
that got very personal very fast
what I can tell you I can tell you that
there's no way my 40-minute program is
going to satisfy what it is you want you
to do now let me spend listen what I do
promise to do is make sure that people
who watch this program will have an idea
that this other reality exists thank you
for talking to me okay the unedited
version of this encounter can be found
online but to be fair I must emphasize
we did not have a similar conversation
with the people who dispute these views
I'm standing here in I either it is one
of the oldest Palestinian refugee camps
and tell us what does this represent the
opening here this is the gate of 1948
it's implies that the right of return
for the refugees
our grandfathers they were forced to
leave their villages their houses so
they they hold the keys after 60 years
we are waiting for the international
community to implement the UN resolution
194 that gave us the right to return for
our homeland UN resolution 194 came in
the aftermath of Israel's first war with
their Arab neighbors whether the
refugees fled their homes or were forced
from their homes is still a hotly
disputed question to this day the
children that live here are they growing
up in a situation where they have no
expectation that they'll be peace we as
Palestinians we are teaching the people
that we will have peace on this land we
can live together here would it be
possible for me to go in and talk to
some people is that possible yes we can
go hello what is your name do you live
here in either I was born in Ithaca
do you feel like people in America
understand what's happening here so you
know we have a problem with
government but we don't have any problem
with with the people and I tried before
to travel to America but they accuse my
visa
mm-hmm you couldn't get it easy to come
here because at that time I went to
continue my master's degree there
what was your master's in environmental
studies Wow very impressive person yeah
yeah best of luck to you thank you did
these guys all grow up in that here in
HIDA yes who's the cool one here who's
the coolest guy here yeah they're the
cool guys I suppose there's always one
if you get three kids together there's
always really there's one cool guy that
you're the boss right yeah yeah what do
they want to say to kids their age in
America would they like to come visit
America sunblock yes what would you like
to see the Statue of Liberty do you want
to see that yes okay you want to be
drunk that's the guy you want to meet
last month oh my god
you